[Music]
in waiting till marriage news submitted
by Joe Molly and timekeeper Oh where's
Joe Mallya that's his that's his land my
dreams country fine okay I'll have rolls
and everything nice
a dolphin a Dolphins cheerleader says
she faced discrimination after revealing
her virginity that's funny because when
you read it I pictured I thought
dolphins you thought dolphins Miami
Dolphin and how do you reveal your
virginity like this dolphin cheerleader
I saw a dolphin a cheerleader outfit on
a dolphin you saw that yeah I was like
how did this she continued to say sorry
and I'm like oh and then it just went to
normal town it's being about pearl from
Sponge Bob yeah yeah that's a whale but
like that's true yeah so this extra
cheerleader her name was Kristin she so
four cheerleaders have to renew they're
like the real license reapply for the
job okay every season I guess and so
when she was reapplying to enter her
third year she went into her annual work
review and that's when it turned out
that they told her that she can no
longer speak about her virginity
something like you got to be a hole up
in here mm-hmm we only accept hose I
mean I don't know but yeah and so
apparently they they had like a speck of
papers they're like let's talk about
your virginity and then she ended up
leaving the office but then she was told
by two coaches that she could no longer
talk about her virginity but that she
only mentioned it once when it was like
during a bus trip with like other
cheerleaders there
talking about like their own sexual
experiences and she was like oh well
saving myself because of my religion and
I'm gonna be saving myself into a
marriage and so apparently that got to
the ears of the coaches and then
everyone else what's the problem she's
saying she got discriminated because
during that same that same work review
thing they made her go and dress into
like this bikini and during that like
while she was raining that they were
having a photo shoot and then there were
people that were just like poking fun at
it kind of like oh like just be more
sexual or certain things like make it
dirty or something like that I don't
know it's just the way their wording ms
is just for her she felt so
discriminated and to the point where she
had to like she ended up going home [ __ ]
too because if it's like a religious
thing for her that's pretty [ __ ] bad
that's like yeah it's it's [ __ ] up but
I can also see why they do that so like
we're never like in a sports team or if
you're like in the military or whatever
there's like this level of camaraderie
and the minute they find out one thing
that's an outlier everyone clowns on you
and clowns on you hard and it's part of
the camaraderie or the fraternity or the
sorority of that group so for her I
don't know where her upbringing is but
like let's say she wasn't used to that
type of like locker room like joking and
[ __ ] around it could probably really
really get to her I think like even a
sports no they wouldn't [ __ ] with
religion though but you leave that [ __ ]
alone you could talk about your mom
whatever your dad but it feels like
religious [ __ ] you didn't what you
wouldn't touch that [ __ ] if you're like
let's say you're a football player and
you're a virgin you're gonna be the
engine and then entirely locker when
people are taking showers and we'll be
clowning on you that virgin dirt they're
gonna be like everyone's gonna be going
in on you and that's like the same type
of sports culture and one of this house
like for cheerleaders to ban so I mean
you could I could imagine some women
literally being bitter because she's a
virgin
like so that it could it could spark
that coming from there apparently she
was told that she could talk about her
virginity in private but never around
the team and that she needed to become a
woman yeah that's just [ __ ] up friend
a whole policy that's more than just
locker room [ __ ] around yeah and then
during that photo shoot I mentioned that
they had her play with fruit and they
told her play with it like their balls
and make love to the camera and like she
felt like they were just walking her
like kind of do sounds like locker room
talk yeah the other stuff was a little
weird though yeah yeah yeah okay what's
wrong with what I mean
playing with fruit like a drink no honey
with some fruit like it's balls
oh but like I mean if she exposed that
and then now they're like it is their
mom I guess it is kind of like it's a
little bit like bullying I think the the
issue the biggest issue that I see is
like telling her she can't talk about it
with with them she has to keep it secret
all these things it's like that's going
beyond the line you know it's like she
could talk about it whenever the [ __ ]
she wants it's not violating anything
yeah at first the economy did seem like
she was like going to news outlets in
like I'm the only Miami cheerleader
that's veldt like a virgin everybody
else said Oh like you know that's what I
was yeah that's what I thought too
yeah then I could totally see them
saying something to her about it also
because I feel like they kind of want to
sexualize the cheerleaders because when
you think about having sex with a
cheerleader you think it like dirty
nasty like wouldn't it be good to have
someone that is a virgin in your team
because it's like oh she's the Virgin
one I [ __ ] her and then the other guys
like nah I want someone with experience
I [ __ ] her and then like they're like
talking about the team yeah I feel like
they could have exploited it or just you
know told her like you know I don't know
but I feel like because they're like
don't talk about it around the team it's
more like the girls are probably bitter
about it you like it's causing too many
issues like too much drama
yeah yeah well the whole thing here
though is like they're trying to like
highlight the workplace conditions um
and I felt you cheerleaders because
there was this
former Redskins cheerleader who said
that the team once sold an appearance
where the cheerleaders would show up to
a residence and do nothing but just hang
out with men drinking beer which is like
that's kind of like hoeing them out
pretty much yeah yeah until that's weird
I don't like the discussion here the
workplace environment for NFL
cheerleader yeah so they're they're kind
of like glorified I guess escorts I mean
like I feel like years ago that probably
wasn't the thing but that could also be
a result of like and it feels not to me
as well as it was ten years ago and so
maybe they are like trying to exploit
you know these beautiful women that they
have and try to like do something with
that I feel like it's more likely to
happen in the past and it is now because
it's more hidden in the past maybe maybe
we just didn't know about it but I mean
because that is a different angle like
because I don't I I knew that they were
cheerleaders to every team but I cannot
name a single cheerleader for like
Dallas or like I've never even seen them
do you even see them you just kind of
see them on the time that pace sucks ass
yeah you can't even you have to do that
and be like a dance teacher or like do
whatever yeah I don't think I've ever
seen a cheerleader for like the Super
Bowl or something and like if they I'm
sure they're there briefly but like I
don't see like a major portion with them
or anything yeah I'm never like wow
Jessica from the Dallas Cowboys she's
best yeah I think like cheerleaders too
like their [ __ ] jobs are hard you
think they would get paid more because I
heard that shit's like [ __ ] like you
have to be dangerous Popkin yes it's
dangerous I was I was I forget what you
call it a fly fly girl or whatever I was
a cheerleader like that's the person on
top take that throw him or something
yeah yeah is that you yeah I did I and I
only did that for like a year because I
guess it was scary and like oh my god I
totally forgot about this I'm having
flashbacks now dog [ __ ] I got yeah they
were mad at me because I didn't want to
like keep climbing to the top and then
like dad some dude it was like 14 that
had to like hold me you have to like
stand on somebody's feet like this and
like yeah I don't know you I don't trust
you dawg like I don't have time for all
that's [ __ ] crazy and then like and
then when they won she got they like
hold you like this and then they kind of
launched you a little bit ending didn't
they catch it's so scary they want to
dress up as a girl and I want to
complain that the discriminating gets me
because I'm fat because I want to be on
top I'm not a base okay I'm the icing on
the [ __ ] cake you better put me on
top [ __ ] I want to be up on top
and I want to see that [ __ ] in my head
like he's praising the Lord super like a
girl yeah I might listen [ __ ] I'm the
top you're the [ __ ] bottom let that
was on dodgeball remember oh yeah yeah
that's how I wanted to be that's how it
is dawg it's a dangerous as looking job
like you got to go up there if twirl
around shits like just how many times
did that girl fall down before they got
that right yeah I'm not I'm not gonna
lie look like a lot of fun what's baby
yeah being the top girl like I wanted to
be that social media though has changed
up like the the cheerleader fetish
though because I don't think I don't
really back it was like do cheerleader
are [ __ ] hot now kind of like it's
just a cheerleader I think there's like
more [ __ ] out there that's bit like I
rather the I'm being the equivalent to
how hot a cheerleader girl was toss back
a day is now Instagram girl yeah yeah
cuz like before that appeal of being a
cheerleader I believe was that you were
the hot chick you were the popular team
not just like and you you were you could
wear short [ __ ] and get away with it
yeah girls volleyball though that [ __ ]
was tight yeah cuz the girls girls
volleyball the game is it's all about
the game my game is really good yeah
it's a really good sport yeah right when
they start the [ __ ] they go
[Music]
no a lot of guys that my game it's the
only sport one of the guys root for both
sides
oh okay which team's plan volleyball is
under for the volleyball girls were
underrated I didn't even know what
volleyball was I just call it booty
Sports we watching booty sports today
all right you caught me I wanted to be a
low pro ho that's I joined oh and then
you know believe it or not the swim team
is usually the least sexiest could be
built as [ __ ] you would think like
swimsuit and all that but it's like it's
not sexual and then swim has this thing
that you can they just look like an
erect dick with the condom on that's all
that's all they look like guys too
little speedos with the thing in the
news that's the guys weren't covered up
like if they're Jack they're jack but
girls it's like straight covered up
yeah see any man they were just really
buff and their skin was peeling all the
time so it just was like yeah that's
like such PETA to do [ __ ] for them you
know I mean like their shoulders were
always peeling you know hi David like
why don't you get rid of that [ __ ] first
before you way stop talking here just
dust coming up I don't know Rosa but
they could but they could rescue you if
you jur if you're drowning yeah [ __ ]
funny to play just fine
[Music]
[Music]